bien des musiciens débutants aux
confirmés rêve ces jours ci du record
absolu toutes catégories et à l'est par
l'une des chansons des beatles yesterday
signée lennon mccartney diffusée à la
radio et à la télé plus de 5 millions de
fois avec évidemment à les droits
d'auteur conséquent patrick vilaire
gast et d en maillechort rosine sauf à
imaginer plus de 140 mille heures
consécutives à écouter la même chanson
encore et encore
record du monde record qui vient d'être
établi pour y est des la fameuse chanson
des beatles
140 mineurs cela fait 28 ans ou plus de
5 millions de passages à la radio ou à
la télévision quand on sait que geste
des n'a que 23 ans d'âge une seule
chanson pour des millions de dollars de
droits d'auteur yesterday représente
tout simplement l'une des quatre de
liverpool
ce chiffre comprend les versions des
beatles mais également les multiples
adaptations par des chanteurs comme ray
charles ou frank sinatra dans le même
temps hollywood honoré john lennon sur
la fameuse rock of fame l'allée du
succès une étoile à son nom était
dévoilée en présence de yoko ono
cb